now I told you that luckily the way to
earn money was all the different ways
fall under two four categories the first
one I guess which regularly comes which
should've closed you in to the fact that
the other category is irregular this is
not like so two claims two main kinds of
irregular income that I'm going to tell
you about just like with regular the
first kind of irregular income which is
the simplest not Tanana is what we call
Pete work which is exactly what it
sounds like every time you do a piece of
work you get people also often this is
with physical objects so for example if
you are on you know a food vendor a food
center then the more pieces of to
yourself I the more money that you earn
okay so this is pretty straightforward
you just have to work out your actual
income is going to be the number of
items if you're the person making them
maybe you get paid to number items views
things even the vehicle and then you
just multiply that by whatever the
individual price
the revised tribes individual price it
is worth commenting this is not
something you really deserve it is
relevant because just the practical
things in your purses and your the
actual might buy all the stuff to make
the foods of any scale the triple right
you don't actually make this amount of
money as a profit figure out this right
suppose you're selling you're making and
selling like sushi rolls right maybe you
sell each roll for three dollars a piece
and then you sell a hundred so that is
if I see a hundred times three well $300
is not going to be your profit why not
why not yeah running do that yeah so
it's a rice and the seaweed and other
ingredients you're putting because
presumably you have more than just rice
and seaweed very much money as you've
also got like if you employ someone to
help you remember those first two things
salary the wage you're going to have to
pay a human being for that and that will
cut into your income you might have a
shot that shops not free that space that
you are using up it takes money so we
call all of these things over here right
you have to pay for those and once you
pay for all of those then you work out
how much you've actually made now pho be
serviceable but what if these a little
more thought is sort of halfway between
peace worth and that regularly comes off
that I mentioned before we call them
Commission
okay now just like with all I asked you
feel like a succinct one sentence
definition for wage or salary is anyone
willing to offer off the sentence that
would describe what is commissioned
there Brian under love yeah very good
so same in Germany right pay us the more
you sell the more you make right
commissions time to like that but
basically you're selling something just
belong to someone else so they give you
the whole done instead is done yeah
that's right set up to centage all sales
revenues the way we say okay so here's
the idea
you're a salesperson maybe you work at
Harvey Norman and you still produced
maybe you're working a real estate agent
you're selling property okay now if
you're really completed so property
might be like a bizarre thousands all of
those is 1.2 million goal something like
that you don't get all of that revenue
as the real estate agent you just get a
portion of that potential and 19 to be
remised it it kind of fluff away this
condition I do it's halfway between
peace work and that stuff that wage
stuff Valerie some as anyone will know
for example you might remember when we
had those heat waves and that kind of
thing right if your sales tested for air
conditioners you'll having a great time
everyone is sold out of total air
conditioners right in winter you're
going to sell lots of air condition is
still because they were one heating but
it time like now anyway there's quite
temperate your sales revenues it might
not go to zero but it's going to draw
very shot okay so many kinds of sales
are what we call anyone know what for
when is different times in a year just
more or less
period high and low they all come in the
same umbrella what we call seasonal like
because literally hot this it goes with
the team now because your income
therefore is lots people right it's
irregular this one that you have good
once you have bad luck in order to make
sure you can actually still regolith it
good places that higher self it or
reservation for whatever they provide
what's called a retainer now I know how
many of you have braces I have I had
braces and after you have braces you get
them out and then you get a retainer
what is your retainer doing anyway it's
keeping them in place right in your bows
now Jesus be right this is automotive
whatever they want to do to you as the
sounds of this exactly what you want to
do your teeth you know what your sales
persons just leave because they have
their income you need to hold on to them
you need to retain them which is what
the retainer is the percentage of sales
of these so if it goes up and down but
the retainer is a regular income to
offset the fact that well this is all
irregular we don't want you if you have
a bad bug that just like have no money
and be on the street so you pay you a
little bit regularly to hold on next I
said I will show you how that works